dr. Porter you have just put out a
report on fracking help us untangle this
as as we figure this out state by state
city by city what is the right way to
think about this decision that counties
have to make about fracking well I think
I think it's interesting that fracking
has become kind of a dirty word or swear
word in America and and yet fracking is
is a remarkable innovation that's
allowed the United States to actually
achieve a substantial advantage in
energy energy costs the cost of
electricity the cost of natural gas it's
the single biggest driver of where our
economic growth right now and yet
communities are fighting it and the
reasons are there's a very political
debate about the environmental impacts
environmental implications and we did
this report to try to sort out what's
really going on here and what the
country should do could the oil and gas
industry be more transparent about what
they're doing in order to assuage these
concerns the cities have we think so
this study was done with Bossk
Consulting Group one of the leading it's
all in terms of the world we did it as a
partnership with HBS to really try to
understand this issue the industry is
making a lot of progress the
environmental issues are being improved
and improved and improved but the
industry has been very untransparent
they've they've sort of been taking on
these communities and advocating their
cause I think they've made the problem
work one of the advantages you have is a
double degree in engineering from
Princeton and aerospace and mechanical
engineering there's a deep distrust of
the technology and technological
progress of this science is it valid
science and will it not cause
earthquakes in Oklahoma well there's
very significant environmental impacts
Tom that happened in a variety of ways
water seismic and others but if actually
look at the data and look at the
progress that we're making on actually
minimizing those risks the progress is
substantial and we can make more and
what's really important is you can
reduce those risks reduce that water
issue reduce that those flaring issues
at very low costs so there's no right
why we can't make price
what are the risks how do we quantify
them well there's a whole variety of
risks they they fall into a number of
buckets water risk where there's a lot
of water used in this process and the
question is are we going to pollute that
water and then there's issues of
injecting that water back into the
ground that's what actually causes the
earthquakes there there's issues in
congestion there's issues of chemicals
there's issues of you know land we're
gonna have a seven Richter earthquake in
New York State I mean the sidebar in New
York State yeah is interesting and that
they basically said there's no science
we really don't know what's going on so
we're just to stop doing it well that's
even if there's no so that's the
European approach I mean this is one of
the things I that I think fascinating
about American competitors you're pink
but Europeans say you've got to prove to
us that there's that there's no harm
before you can do it Americans say
you've got to prove to us that there is
harm before we stop you yeah well and
and and the problem is that the industry
was in denial on the earthquakes they
just said oh there's no earthquake yeah
okay there are earthquakes I mean the
data is overwhelming now that we're
starting the earthquakes we know why
they happen it's the injection wells we
know that when you do those wells near a
fault you have an earthquake if you stay
away you don't we can solve this problem
but we're having such a politicized
debate that we're actually not moving
ahead and Brendan this is the biggest
economic opportunity America has for the
foreseeable future this is what's
driving whatever little economic growth
we have right now we've got to work
through a win/win pathway here where we
can get this economic benefit while
dealing with these legitimate
environmental issues to get these
legitimate environmental issues right
what is the proper role of the state and
federal governments what could be done
well I think the the they're they're
moving the states now most states highly
regulate this the regulatory standards
are getting better and better there's
there's cross state collaboration now to
make the standards the the most
effective and the most up-to-date but
you know states have gaps to fill and
the biggest issue is more not this
regulation but the compliance states are
still struggling with making sure that
all the industry operators are actually
following the rules and it turns out
that a lot of the people you know they
Darko's you know I have tremendous
record it's it tends to be the little
guys that are that are not so so quickly
this nice reporter you're gonna give a
barrier to entry to the Department of
Energy tell them to go away not go away
Tom but we need to approach this in a
way right now in America we're paralyzed
for making progress on the most
important issues we face on Tax Policy
on trade policy on immigration policy
we're having the same problem here on
energy it's our biggest advantage it's
it's it's it's historic okay but yeah
we're having a big fight across the
stakeholders rather than getting
together and figuring out how to solve
these problems and they can be solved